what's good brother you met my dad your
dad was fantastic papa chappelle met
papa chappelle was he wearing a hat he
was wearing a hat he's always dressed
he's always dressed he had some jewelry
on a great guy and by the way uh you
sound a lot like him you know they look
similar he's a chip off the old block
did you get a pick with him i don't know
i don't even know i don't even know with
him too and send it to chapelle oh yeah
i posted it oh really yeah it's just
them meeting oh he's he's great man yeah
he's a great dude huh he loves you man
he's so proud of you you oh you guys got
to like talk so moving to me he came to
the green room yeah he said to me he
said my son's got such guts man i would
never have had that the kind of guts he
had oh he said when i said them i said
yeah but
you and your example and what you went
through it might be the reason he's a
comic so everybody everybody contributes
man i thought this was your dad's
instagram like jesus christ he posts a
lot of you
that'd be funny get off his nuts
he's great man he's a great dude man
yeah yeah he was he was so he was so
stoked
uh to meet you he he messaged me this
morning he goes uh
he goes uh man you got some good people
in your life man i'm proud of you what
you're doing he goes but uh enough with
the emotional [ __ ] what's good this
morning like
that's just how he is like let me see a
video
uh yeah oh it's cardinal's hat's lit
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah we do sound alike it's kind of
crazy to hold your dad
uh no you're he's younger than you he's
20 younger than us 20 i think he's
younger than you
yeah because he was like
he ought to say i was like i don't think
you're the same age
he's young because he had me yeah he had
me and my brother young yeah i think
when my brother was born i think he was
like 17. he was a juvie so he's about
48. he was a juvie when my mom was
pregnant your dad's probably 40
something no he's not 47 40. no he's in
his 50s i think he's 50. he might be 52.
he'd be 52. he's 50. he's 52. yeah he's
52. about three years oh so yeah yeah i
mean yeah he's 52. hey yo
let me tell you something all right i
want both of you to know this yeah
springfield missouri you've said this
because you wonder why i say it about
this one it's because i had low
expectations because i was like oh
springfield
yeah no
pop
pop lit really lit tom segura was uh
doing the theater like right across the
street from whatever it's a it's an
improv or what is the no it's called
blue room comedy club right i think it
suits about like two something yeah okay
man you know like when we went to boise
yeah it was just yeah that's how it is
there i i don't know if there's
something with the small smaller towns
yeah yeah well a lot of a lot of big
guys don't go through there i'm guessing
yeah so like i mean i listen if i did
well there and i can only imagine what
y'all would saturday saturday in arizona
at stand up live
and ally mccoskey
jumped on for uh gas head she killed it
yeah yeah luis kevin mack
everybody agreed i i don't know if i've
ever had crowds that electric i actually
don't know
the first show was
so crazy sometimes it's so weird how a
crowd can be just depends it's literally
like they're on led they're on adderall
or stuff yeah yeah
you know it was just unbelievable just
everything and sometimes that is but but
places like springfield they don't get a
lot of comedy maybe and when you show up
i'm thinking yeah i don't know it was in
like i'm doing it i've been like a
downtown no i'm telling you brian i'm
gonna do it you will really love it they
have a nice little it's not a big
downtown yeah i like this small town
yeah the smaller surprise great coffee
shops great uh restaurants because
that's what they i think that's what
they kind of like yeah it's just like a
small town why would we have like good
food and like good yeah is there a
mystery
dope bar there's a bar called j-o-b or
something like that you went to the uh
huh you went to the bar well my buddy
when my guy
but they had great food he's got some
great little towns and their thing there
is a
cashew chicken they're known for their
cashew chicken
that's what they're known for an asian
dish
that's what they told me you know but i
actually had a really really really good
time i thought i was going to cheat on
my diet at hattie b's in nashville
because
he was still doing that yeah still on it
brian dorfman brought hattie beast for
everybody in the green room and i was
like oh now's the time yeah and i took
one small bite and i'm like i'm just not
feeling it yeah and j so jay ate mine so
now you've been on you've been on the on
on meat and whiskey for how long now two
months okay that's it
when did i do when was tough mudders in
january yeah yeah that was january yeah
yeah longer and yeah longer than that
two and a half no was it changing no
yeah it was january because yeah and it
was around your birthday yeah yeah
because that was the thing we were like
we're doing this okay for our birthdays
yeah so about two and a half months wow
i mean i cheat but i did cheat last
night and my girls make some food and
it's been problems ever since i don't
know your stomach is [ __ ] up yeah i
bet i don't want to cheat you when beans
and and peppers get in those is the
fried like the tortillas and stuff
because i had carbs and all my god yeah
my god yeah it'll it'll bloat you up too
not fun no it's a problem nashville was
great though yeah you look like you're
having a blast yeah it's so much fun
the stefano jeff dye was there yeah
jelly roll came got
by the way go back to uh i don't know
you did busting with the boys well
compton our boy will and uh
now take a look at brandon well he's a
pro ball offensive left look at that guy
he makes you
look very small
how tall is that guy
six six seven i mean he played it you
don't see him dude he's a all pro dude
he's a monster he's a monster
those boys that's a big boy boys are
game changing what they're doing they
take the bus now and they go to the
spring camps of the football team
they're in nebraska university nebraska
last week they're in michigan this week
wow that's a dope game i love will how
great as well the best guy
his wife's do any day now really any day
now wow
and they're through barstool they're
through barstool yeah they're doing
their thing yeah they're crushing they
have a new facility now yeah so cool man
you still go inside the bus but last
time we were literally outside in the
nashville hot sun and they had no ac
we're dying
so now they really stepped their game up
man yeah those boys are crushing it
jelly roll i warned everybody in the
green room i said
jelly is gonna offer you more alcohol
than you've ever seen in your life
you gotta say no yeah you can have one
or two you gotta say no yeah nobody
listens no david threw up brother threw
what
jay was through everybody got drunk jay
missed the bus with the boys
jeff was hammered
so now and then jeffrey and i went yeah
and i went home early like went to the
show house in nashville and i was like
all right i'm out of here like where you
going i'm like dude i gotta be up at
eight to do a pod i got this appearance
for my whiskey yeah i can't be out man
well dad daddy did everybody else stay
yeah i i i ended up doing um
sugar shawn's uh podcast we had a blast
he's [ __ ] great tim walker's great
they're [ __ ] i had a good podcast for
those guys i had a lot of fun
and he uh
he's gonna be it's really he's a very
very smart guy look at him he's a silly
goose always dressed like that he's he's
negotiating uh his contract right now
really really do you see himself mm-hmm
he's doing himself
yeah and then
the weight room he's doing it himself
man
damn yeah he's abusive do you see your
boy cleo roundtree yeah did you see his
interview yeah
powerful powerful i didn't very
like very very emotional he's on food
truck
cleo's gonna be on food oh he's gonna be
a food truck wait why would he win
i'll play it real quick oh wow let me
see it probably yeah friday yeah i text
him right after because i was in the
i was in the green rooms right right
before i went on stage i didn't pay
attention did he retire chabelle is that
his last one i thought no no he just he
said i want to tell my story
but like he goes i want i want to talk
about brian just so you know he was like
bullied he was 300 pounds
when i met him he was selling uh fight
gear you do the one right otm fight shop
in huntington beach wait so he was the
one
really he was huge 200 pounds he's
jacked now yeah wow
you've seen him before b
yeah yeah alex
um i saw one one one question for you
man um for the next clue that's maybe
staying on his couch right now a little
bit overweight um what's your message to
him
he's got a knockout win too
destroy the guy oh yeah
it might sound a bit
cliche or we've heard this before but
like your life matters
wow
wow
jesus
he's thinking about all the [ __ ] he had
to face
together he was 300 pounds
bullied all that [ __ ] god you gotta love
this guy yeah you can be special
you can be
strong you can be seen
you can be heard
life is beautiful
if you make it that way
it doesn't have to be
how everybody else makes it seem
stick around
stick around another day
i would have a lot of
a lot of things like that to say man
thank you absolutely crazy huh yeah i
know how do you not love a guy like that
how do you love somebody else you like
when you when you see that kind of
moment where he just pauses you just
all the things he went through it's just
like that's the journey that's the
journey the thing about the right thing
it took for him to get oh my god like
from legitimate 300 pounds and you've
never seen the before and after
you know and by the way is there any way
to avoid that journey to become a
complete human being too it's like
there's something so beautiful about
that struggle man it's just like
beautiful look at that oh i've seen this
yeah yeah
the mustache
what a stud
come on man you got a little hey
shredding first team all body now jesus
first team all by that crazy god damn it
dude i got to start getting some tasks
yo to thailand yep yeah you've been
fighting for a while now i think he said
it's 12 years he's been
i thought he was talking about retiring
this was his last one am i right i
didn't mention he's a 205 yeah but but
now he's talking about
he's going to continue yeah
so nuts man that that fight was crazy
not dude
dude
he pride style kicked
kicked him and just i mean and then dude
got up and then he just got him with a
good dishes yeah
super vicious lord have mercy you're
such a good person yes such a good guy
like just you still talk to him all the
time yeah yeah i text him right after
his interview and he you know text me
back and stuff and just been chopping it
up with him like i don't know i just i
remember when i first
initially heard about him it was just
like fans tagging me in his because he's
in a punk rock yeah yeah so fans were
tagging me in his post and then uh then
he started following me i started
following him and then we just became
homies
he's a good dude speaking of violence i
had a bit of an experience i trained a
trained uh um but i trained in firearms
this uh weekend how'd you do what is it
so what is it it's like a simulation
yeah so a guy named travis haley has a
haley strategics uh i sent these videos
to rogue and i have a bunch of them and
rogan was like i'm getting one of these
things in my house
this is a simple one that they train you
on if you're a swat guy special forces
guy where they teach you they can put
you in any kind of situation right any
kind of like situation active shooter
active shooter situation in a dark room
in a house in a movie theater
and the laser on the bullet the the
laser and is is perfectly accurate it's
exactly like shooting out okay did you
get to pick what situation be uh no i
did not they don't tell you okay oh by
the way one one other thing you're
wearing
a 10 000 volt
uh
contraption on your naked skin so if you
get shot
and you don't get you don't kill the guy
and sometimes i gotta have a bulletproof
vest on you're gonna you're gonna get
shocked for two and a half seconds and
it [ __ ] really sucks you really feel
it well you'll see well you'll see what
happens to me here hell no but they take
you through this whole thing now i don't
know what's going on watch this there's
like all right you're up buddy and you
don't know you're going to be in a movie
theater nope nothing watch
now are you standing i know right oh
this would make me puke well because
you're now you're nervous guys if i if i
get shot i'm gonna get shocked the [ __ ]
parasympathetic right gauge your vagus
nerve
there's travis teaching me how to
breathe
see that thing on my back right there
that's a hostage situation
think about what your eyes are doing
right now
you see how the blood
is
i don't know if i want this in my life
this is they they train you and it's so
scary now it's all now i'm walking by
it's 360 it's 180 is there something
it's it's
it's it's almost 360.
there's a screen behind me and
everything's not be if you shoot an
innocent person running will they fall
down yes which i did i shot i shot a cup
i shot a cop yeah
so watch yeah watch so much i'm being
distracted watch this
[Music]
we're being hired to play these actors
see i shot him this time
this guy was coming out with a gun but
it was a cop
you shot him here first
time all right
i'm filming right now
see that guy shot at me and i almost
killed him down cop got hit on mountain
killed brian killed the cop
no i didn't kill the kids no i'm good
here i'm good here so far now i don't
know what the [ __ ] is going to happen
now remember if i get hit that thing is
going to shock me so badly see
this is what cops deal with this is what
swat team does this is what special
forces guys and you can do this with an
am an m16 yeah or m4 and it's got a
really crazy charge it's so it's so
addictive it's crazy now look it's
darkness watch
your eyes
what there's a 27 minute video brian
doing this
this is one of those simulations they do
now it's really loud too you can't tell
here it's really loud so you're
everything and they measure everything
that you're doing you're breathing and
everything to be presented with now
watch this
yeah outdoor world now no you're
outdoors
don't shoot
see he had a gun now watch this [ __ ]
what's this
oh shoot shoes
tossed it
off i killed her though i [ __ ] got
her she was a bad guy yeah i got her i
got her but she got me first
but i got him but dude you guys look at
how i'm sweating i'm sweating that [ __ ]
burned me i my back was burning for two
hours after that my back was still that
bad yeah it's that bad and then i do
another one where i got [ __ ] caught
too yeah so what they do is they do this
yeah they go you hear the dispatch and
it says in the the second one i did the
dispatch says
shooter bulletproof vest so i hear a
shooter but then what happens is the
woman comes running around she goes
she's screaming they're in there they're
in there i didn't hear they so i thought
there was one dude so i killed one dude
who i with a headshot he had a
bulletproof vest so i had to get his
head and and then i was like i got him
and the [ __ ]
yeah i relax and the guy
i discharged the shotgun and i go like
that
as i'm dying i [ __ ] went boom boom
but i caught him in the head as i died
it was good so while i was being shocked
i got that [ __ ] that shock
treatment look intense as well
scenarios was there every scenario you
can imagine they'll put you in okay and
they can control it so they can they can
put like a cop comes in they can put a
guy who shoots you they can do they're
different every time
every time
and they want if i go through it i'm not
gonna like i saw that
there are infinite numbers of this this
is uh this is this is yeah this guy
travis so this guy travis haley
is i he didn't he's a very quiet guy
this this dude's not going to tell you
anything about what he did but he was
for he was recon marine and then he went
on to do other [ __ ] you know one of
those guys and i know about him because
he was the blackwater sniper he was the
guy they caught bring up blackwater
sniper on youtube for are we allowed to
show this on youtube no probably not not
blackwater sniper even though it's okay
it he was the first guy to go viral
during the iraq war where he like six
other dudes it fizzles yeah just bring
up blackwater snipers so you can see
what the [ __ ] he was doing and they
actually caught him he didn't know what
he was doing he was just all he was
doing was working he was holding off he
was holding off 1600 insurgents they
were trying to close in right here and
he's just taking these guys out and this
went
this this went viral i won't be able to
use anything but just watch watch what
he's doing here he's just taking you
down
because they keep they're kind of trying
to come in on him
they were everywhere the mahdi army you
got a group of three they're all running
now and he was he was reconciling they
call them the jack they call them jacks
jacks of all trades
so they can do they can do underwater
[ __ ] they can do sniper stuff they're
all you know they're only i believe uh
in these recon guys they're only uh
something like a hundred of those or
three hundred okay period the level of
calmness yeah yeah right now a whole
different thing that's where delta gets
there guys yeah they're in iraq jesus
guys yeah this is no joke man he's just
like it just goes on and on and but this
went this went
like you can hear him talking this went
viral because then there's a second part
there's a whole bunch there's a whole
bunch of video on this guy
and his team doing crazy [ __ ] but again
you meet him and he's got he's a very
successful businessman now he's got all
this stuff but dude that it's called
haley strategists how long i'm going to
hook you up how long has he been yeah
i'm in you and rogan when you guys go
there rogan's like i want to go april
14th yeah yeah i said to travis i go
rogan wants one in his studio and travis
like i can make it happen
but do here i mean i wouldn't want that
my studio it's so it's such a good thing
to practice though it actually is
because it teaches you how to kind of
stay calm in every weird alertness but
you actually learn a lot about yourself
too like you learn a lot
and it's really interesting that makes
sense yeah
because because what they always try to
do is that the biggest problem with
teaching swat or anybody in combat
situations is you can't mimic combat
it's like what you always say there's
there's training sparring and then
there's actual fight right
and it's a little bit like that like
where they where they're always trying
to figure out a way to get you to be
able to see [ __ ] that you your eye
reacts way faster than your body so what
they want you to do is your body and
your eye to do it together yeah your
mind works really quickly but you'll do
crazy [ __ ] and a lot of cops and a lot
of people in those situations people
don't realize no if you don't train all
the time and even then you hit you you
shoot freeze up you shoot civilians
that's why when there's an active
shooter situation they always say you
should carry a gun in case you're there
you know what happens if i'm there and
i'm in a mall and there's an active
shooter situation and i'm like i'm gonna
i'm gonna no i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna do i'm trying i'm gonna kill this
guy when cops come into that arena when
they see it they shoot you right away
yeah you're done because they're like
he's the shooter they don't know
so there's all so so the other thing
that i'll teach you is to keep your gun
concealed while you're doing that
it's all that stuff
it's it's a thousand things man
oh here's the other [ __ ] crazy thing
they'll they'll have a guy there's a
woman in an atm machine okay and my
buddy kevin kevin's like there and the
guy gets out you see the car pull up
there's a driver actually it's on video
there's a driver and then there's a dude
who gets out and you see the guy walking
up to the girl and he looks at you and
he goes don't get involved
and he goes over and i'll next thing you
know kevin's like what the [ __ ] and he
pulls out a knife and he's got it there
and i'm like shoot up shoot him and
kevin's like what the bi hey hey and the
guy just stabs her and she's dead
too late too late so then they do the
same scenario with me i'm ready bro i'm
ready guy comes out
put i don't even i i see him going he
goes don't get him out i pull my gun the
minute he gets that woman boom boom i
blast him i'm like you're [ __ ] dead
here was the problem that time guy
didn't have a knife oh oh man he didn't
have a knife i didn't i was so jacked up
so what do you do what do you do what do
you do and he said he said that could
have been a guy's he that was an uber
why was he in the back seat i go because
he was trying to he goes or it was an
uber yeah and he goes yeah he's going
over there tell his wife hey what the
hell i've been calling you where were
you and you just shot an innocent man
and so they teach you that [ __ ] unless
you are trained in that yeah being a cop
and being what's even crazier
that helps but even that
it's still like but the more you and the
more you the more rest you uh it's
called the more you inoculate yourself
to stress to stressful situations the
more training you have the more the
safer you're going to be and the better
you're going to be in those situations
and the less likely somebody innocent is
going to die
dude you got to see everything it's like
being a quarterback like a quarterback
can read a field in split second time
yeah the the cops and everyone using his
name
but yes he does very well
he does very well yeah but but but but
they're probably probably not enough
does he have like multiple things going
on or is it just that simulations
yeah well well you also learned so much
to when you see those dudes when you see
those guys shoot like like they're on it
they can hit you with a head shot they
they you can be this close to somebody
in our situation
they with their eyes open
i mean and you can throw them in did he
do a run yeah
i saw his buddy who he trained who
wrestled at purdue but just a strapping
young kid yeah military kid dude i
thought i was a big d i i was kind of
happy with my shots
and then i saw him
yeah i was like oh different [ __ ]
levels oh dude it's
and you don't know what's going to
happen one dude there's a ki there's a
kid and the kid shoots the kid pulls the
gun out and there's a girl on the back
of this four-wheeler now the kid shoots
and one dude now now the one guy shot
the kid right he's just that good but
there's this one swat guy they put in
the stimulator and you know what he did
he dove behind the tractor
and the guys what are you doing because
i'm not shooting a kid i'm getting
behind a tractor i'm going to let him
shoot at me and drive away that's pretty
badass yeah that's a wow that's a badass
[ __ ] that guy knew
even in simulation not to kill the other
kid and he dove behind the [ __ ] and
let him know he didn't get in the
simulation is he like jumping on the
ground no he didn't get like he told me
like one dude go through the screen
because you're so afraid you're going to
get shocked that shock that [ __ ]
tentacle
sucks but it makes it so much more fun
because look what happens to
[Laughter]
but when you go there you're going to
love it you got to do it because you're
close to is yeah it's it's it's 20
minutes away oh okay where you are but
it's so worth it because he's a great
guy yeah
they have scientists there so when you
go there they have a bunch of scientists
that will study your breathing your
parasympathetic response
your eye how your eye tracks that's
actually you can get better and better
it'd be cool to see whose heart rate
gets all crazy what's that called is it
haley haley's strategic yeah haley's
strategic
what a badass but the story i won't say
i won't say the story on on but he
created this company and the story made
me and kevin i was trying not to cry
when he told me the story why he got
choked up why he created it yeah he had
a moment in combat
and uh i won't i won't it's not my place
to say but it was i tried i was trying
not to cry but he told me the story i
could see him get choked up kevin was
like dude i was about to cry go tell me
about it
it it's it's a thing i'll tell you up to
the bear but but it was so powerful for
him that he
he he decided this is i have a liability
in combat and i need to figure out a way
to make sure that i can train people not
to to react yeah
jesus good guy man yeah good [ __ ] guy
where'd you stay where'd you stay at in
phoenix i stayed at the uh palomar but
now you know that's where i used to work
right no dude
you were i know that's where i met you
valerie
from now on daddy stays in uh scottsdale
there's no reason to stand anywhere else
right why you want to stay out there
better it's nice that they're like
i'm a [ __ ] guy yeah you're like okay
it's the best me and brennan
no that's fair we like our restaurants
our coffee shops yeah
we stayed at airbnb in nashville here's
the problem with airbnb is there's no
like official committee on the ratings
and reviews so we stay in this dope
place but it's off the busiest road in
[ __ ] nashville uh it faces the road
dude big problem like i don't know why
they just don't like hey great place
you know if you're here to party and
stuff this is perfect but if you're
trying to sleep or get rest this ain't
the place did you read the reviews
though yeah jay read them they're no
one's because everyone's like they don't
say they're young and they're drunk
no it's not even that big if you leave a
negative review and then they'll come
after you and leave [ __ ] review so
nothing's honest on there oh wow that's
weird they need like an overall
sanctioned body like an official review
like great place on a busy road yeah
i've been because you don't know yeah
yeah you don't know yet i've been burned
a lot with that
that's my problem
it really is five hours
awesome the other half are nightmares i
got one in miami yeah this coming it's
just tough to tell unless you know the
city really really well even if you do
then like yeah unless there's my
hometown that's what i'm saying like if
it's yeah like if it was in arizona i'd
be like yeah that's that's fine yeah i
don't know why yeah but like nightmare
anywhere else it's kind of hard to buy
earplugs i mean yeah i've also gotten
some airbnbs really nice house beautiful
house
in the hood oh yeah yeah oh yeah
they don't tell you no they don't like
that one in kentucky
kentucky i was in the [ __ ] behind a
train track
backyard was a train train i think i
remember that every every two hours
that's right that's right
he's
two in the morning
two in the morning six in the morning
even when we stayed in dallas though
there was gunshots down at by that
7-eleven yeah
yeah
that's funny because i when i was in
dallas i heard gunshots
you are yeah
at two in the morning like like it was a
shooting yeah oh also in nashville snow
dumping snow on friday you don't see
that same as springfield dumping snow
yeah that's why i don't live in
nashville you can do it yeah yeah it's
very cold that's why josh left he was
like dude i didn't know four seasons i
remember going to visit i was at west's
house and and in nashville and i
remember jen brown yeah and i was like
it's so cold here yeah
beautiful house but [ __ ] i was like
but i can do this anywhere dude it was
20 it was 20 hours eastern springfield
east coast it was [ __ ] yeah it's
custom
freezing you'll freeze it was tough yeah
mm-hmm
and and uh arizona this time of year
great weather perfect now the summer
we're going to have a little summer
little day yeah
we're we're not going
70s yeah clear skies in the 70s yeah
it's been [ __ ] gorgeous yeah yeah
it'll be good but when we go there when
are you guys going april 14th
you're doing stand up live yeah april
15th 15th 16th you're going to sell out
and you're going to love it yeah
what am i there training yeah 14th
through 16th i got louisville this
weekend everybody though yeah let me
know how that club is i will i told you
about blue room i like when you go in
the blue room uh i don't know sometime
in uh
i think
i'm telling you you're really gonna like
it i can't wait you're really gonna i
had to push it off a bunch of times but
now i'm gonna go no yeah no you really
like it yeah
good
they're great out there is that me god
daddy's in florida three weekends oh boy
oh [ __ ]
i didn't realize that well well we got
well i got miami no miami 25th 27th and
i think yeah you got it you got a little
bit of time got tampa 15
well we got some florida we got nothing
pandemic anymore daddy there's no reason
to keep it on the floor
everywhere's open yeah how about tiger
school today no mask first date no math
really dude
dude whoever says kids aren't stoked
tigers like dad don't don't even ask
like johnny a mass dude he's like no way
i'm afraid yeah like oh thank god
i it's always been outrageous that kids
had to be in massachusetts
yeah [ __ ] yourself
and i i uh
i think that uh winter planes gonna do
away with masks it was supposed to be
march i think like 18th or 19th but then
they extend for another 30 days really
they say it's tsa is a big reason
because that you know they deal with so
many people
yeah i get it i don't i absolutely do
not yeah it's part of being alive in a
civilization
i can't wait for that day though you
know what sucks so if you're a kid
because it's it's up the discretion of
the parents so i would assume 95
95 parents are like no no mess think
about if you're the kids or your mom
makes you wear a mask yeah i know i
can't stand those people no
they bother me yeah
the the people that when when i remember
when gavin newsom was like take bites
at the at the table in your own home for
thanksgiving
don't sing don't talk about fauci said
and no thanksgiving and yeah and take
your take your mask down to eat and yeah
how about i piss in your mouth though
how about that how would you learn your
mask like you're pissed about douchebag
literally the worst like just people
like that i can't i don't i he's so
insincere he's just so bullish he's just
[ __ ] out of touch with us dude yeah
as a dude
and he's not like
when you hang out with him so i've never
hung out with him
like that yeah yeah good luck with that
yeah
even california is so insincere it's
like yeah i don't know i don't know
anyone that [ __ ] no not at all
because in real life apparently he's a
he's a dude he's a [ __ ] dude no he's
a kind it's like just be a [ __ ] dude
he's just he's not he's a soy boy but i
mean he
he's no matter what we say he don't give
a [ __ ] smart guy the worst would you say
not very smart
good looking guy
what do you got jen what are you keeping
over there what do you get what's the
sound non-stop over there it could
barely hear what's the sound on the
podcast nonstop no because it's it's
boiled eggs that's right i had to get it
further from you guys because it can
smell like oh when you bite myself when
you're buying that thing smell like a
fart it does yeah you tell cats no as
soon as you don't shell it it smells
like a fart oh you're taking the shell
off
you're having a hard boiled egg i'm
having a i'm starving
some [ __ ] hard-boiled eggs man
nothing like that you rock and roll with
those things
something about a hard-boiled egg jen
have you have you been uh i tell you i
told chin this on the shop show
jelly jelly roll wants to be he's going
to start a podcast doing like a seasonal
podcast so i'm going to help him on in
the thick boy but then he's like man i
also want to talk to you about getting
the music business like joe no music man
he's like yeah but the mark and stuff
that you and i can team up like right
and then he's like we have to go after
talent i'm like well you know i don't
know music dude i watch american idol
that's all i got and he's like no we
would start with chin
i was like really and then i was naming
other guys because those other guys are
here he said i'm telling you ching can
do it man he's here i'm like really how
cool is jelly roll man he's [ __ ] yeah
you heard that i know i did they message
me
take yourself
right after that i know that was
beautiful brian you should have seen the
video of him in jelly roll freestyling
in nashville what last year or whatever
yeah they killed it
jim was on the guitar and jelly roll was
very challenging i told joe i said well
you gotta be a little careful because he
blows up like morgan wallin then he's
like on the podcast that's what happens
then you [ __ ] michelle you see how that
works buddy yeah and please stop [ __ ]
gin stop drinking how many asian country
stars are there i but i love all music
but i mean yeah i would definitely do
capture yeah
yeah we know where we're going are you
like we know we yeah we know where we're
going well
hold on are you writing
your own songs i've written a few songs
i hate that i hate that but am i right
curly writing though that's why i said
this but that's why i said to jelly i go
yeah i go chin does all the covers crush
of it we need original music and joey
goes bubba there ain't a better writer
in the game than me yeah he's got to
believe it and just like i love carlos
jelly goes you know how many songs i
write a day i'm like no he's like oh you
know he has like one of the most
trending
country songs in the world chin your job
is to have to quit this podcast no not
leaving ever but i will definitely do an
hour if you're selling out arenas no
dude no now we got to take our twenty
it would help it would help the pot if
chin's like this huge music artist
daddy hey go to go to my story him
singing morgan wallin oh no no no please
chance
i'm telling you chin i don't want to
take yourself very seriously and i need
you to hear what he just said and i need
you to call jelly no it was all right
and i was very [ __ ] do that
and then i need my i need to you've got
to watch me
you got to wet my beak
look at that
get off that
[Music]
mister i take your roses
by the way uh that artist he has an
album out now that's one of jelly's boys
too earnest and that song is with ernest
and morgan wallin oh dope and it's
called flower shops and it
who uh i've been going back and forth
with supposed to meet up this week is
tom mcdonald that that oh yeah the
current event last week
i got in touch with him yeah damn him
and jelly are good boys i was talking
jelly beans like that's my guy and put
us on a group text that's great yeah is
he is he out of nashville too or no he's
in la yeah oh
interesting we're going to meet up
for sure i like that guy sick
interesting yep
yeah jelly knows here buddy yeah yeah he
does and everybody loves him
the most lovable [ __ ] guy oh he's the
best have you met him yet brian mm-hmm
oh you have okay he's going on uh joey
diaz podcast oh hi joey reached out to
him he's got great stories and
everything else great his pot
it crush it yeah all right jim what do
you got all right here we go
b let's take a little break from
chatting with japan just catching up
with the bros man just catching up dude
because listen all you guys out there
you got student loans if you want to pay
after your student loan faster dude yes
it's not good man let's let's talk
student debt all right you could
potentially save thousands with
refinancing all right
federal student loan payments are on
hold but with rates this low now might
be a good time to refinance yep ernest
was voted best student loan refinancing
overall by nerd wallet earnest has some
of the lowest rates flexible payments
and the in-house team ready to help you
out and you never earnest you never pay
fees not late fees dude with earnest you
could change your interest rate get a
lower monthly payment you never pay fees
not even late fees can you talk to a
real live human if you need help with
earnest yeah ernest has actual humans
who are going to talk to you man when
you pay less interest you can put the
money towards your goals with earnest it
takes only two minutes to see what your
new rate could be there's no credit
impact and right now ernest is offering
the fine kid listeners and viewers a
hundred dollars cash bonus refinance
your student debt at earnest.com fighter
not available in all states once again
yep you get a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com fighter
to refinance your student loan visit
owners.com
for more details not available in all
states terms and conditions supply by
earnest student loan refinancing made by
earnest operations llc nmls number 120
4917 california refinancing law
financing law license number 605 4788
535 mission street san francisco
california 94105 visit earnest.com
licenses for our full list of licenses
man it is march and that means march
madness college basketball fans join the
action on the court during the biggest
tournament of the year with draftking
sportsbook turn your team's victory into
your own big win new customers can bet
five dollars on any team to win and get
two hundred dollars in free bets if they
do it's that simple if they win you win
bro if sportsbook isn't available in
your state yet you can still join the
college hoops action with draftkings
pools everyone can play free pools all
march long for a shot at a share of over
250 000 buckaroos and prizes simply join
a pool and answer questions like who
will make it to the next round who will
hit the most three pointers then track
your results you also have ufc london
this saturday watch the kawabas fight
companion 1pm thick boy only youtube
with crystallia jeff dye ufc london bad
on the big fights with the official
sportsman partner of the ufc we'll talk
about draftking sportsbook all you got
to do for march madness and ufc london
download the draftkings sportsbook app
right now use promo code fighter bet
five dollars on any college hoops team
to win and get two hundred dollars in
free bets if they do if they win you win
with promo code fighter this week at
draftking sportsbook gotta be 21 or
older restrictions supply see show notes
for details
so just see
[ __ ] fraud
he was sentenced on friday to 150 days
in cook county he's being held in a
psych ward because
i guess there are uh concerns that he
may be suicidal due to the verdict but
he came out and said that i'm not
suicidal and then kind of alluding to
the fact that someone may try to do
something and that's why he wants
everyone to know that he's not suicidal
he doesn't want to end up like jeffrey
epstein but he ain't like that yeah he's
not
and black lives matter la actually
reposted a photo of him on their
instagram account saying we believe him
this is perfect yeah yeah yeah it says
perfect yeah i love when they get behind
him it's so perfect it shows you how big
of crooks that movement is it's just all
[ __ ] all [ __ ] i think i think
it's definitely not going to help uh
blm's
you know no credibility and that oh
i was that was very very last
credibility i was reading the comments
on it yeah i mean people were going off
about it yeah it doesn't do no one it
does yeah
i just don't understand it like where's
the logic was it was it an official blm
policy or was it just the
uh los angeles chapter or something i
think the los angeles i think it was
just the los angeles no the head of blm
had to step down because they found out
they couldn't figure out where all the
funding was going well she bought
several houses with the money yeah so
she had to step down she's a marxist too
it's interesting kind of a interesting
discussion what's funny is kamala harris
too and biden haven't taken down their
tweets supporting him even after all
this it's hilarious they've supported
him oh yeah in what way come on here
she's like i believe him we gotta stick
by
crime i love it
no it's great that they do well my brain
is just [ __ ] going crazy
you guys want to hear him he's such a
piece of [ __ ]
he's like a piece of [ __ ] like someone
just helped me understand that he's just
doubling down he's a narcissist and this
is what he's a gay tupac is what he said
that's what he did say yeah this is what
news the jury found you guilty in that
sentence i have you have the right to
appeal the findings and rulings to the
court or ask your sentence to be
modified to do those things and you
follow the notice of appeal and writing
within 30 days we also follow he's the
only one wearing a mask which should
have been writing within 30 days
anything not stated and those filings
are waived for purposes of appeal you
cannot afford lawyers and transcripts
they would be provided free of charge do
you have any questions
no i would just like to say to your
honor that i am uh
i am not suicidal
[Music]
okay i'm not suicidal
okay i am not
suicidal i am innocent and i i'm not
suicidal this lawyer's like trying to
tap off
of black americans oh my god and the
fears of the lgbtq community your honor
i respect you and i respect the jury but
i did not do this
they did and if anything happens to me
when i go in there
i did not do it to myself and you must
all know that
i received the sojourn of dramatic
activities
jail time
i am not suicidal okay
mr gucci let me inquire are there any
post-sentencing
i just i i just dramatically i like how
he's like now he's the victim then blm
bmlm is all because of his skin it's
more evidence this is systematic racism
and our judicial system no no no yeah
that's exactly what bmw said no no this
[ __ ] created this entire scenario and
tried to screw over everybody and then
got busted yes
and and yeah i mean obviously it's it's
so weird it drives me crazy it's
hilarious it doesn't do any it doesn't
matter
i'm literally like it doesn't do any
good to stand behind i don't feel like
it's real life and it doesn't do any
good to entertain his yeah drama
dramatic denials
i know he walked out of the courtroom
raising his fist in the air
i was like dude you [ __ ] wrote i was
like hey man if you just should be like
hey i [ __ ] up i think most people
would be like yeah
you know
he's he's you know like he's hurting
your culture by doing that yes i'm like
if you just owned up and just like
what's wrong with you owning up what's
wrong with you on i mean you want to be
paid more and all that okay cool cuckoo
but like
just own up to be like you know what man
i was going through some crazy [ __ ]
whatever guy like that's not going to
take ownership oh gosh it's [ __ ] well
he was already apparently before that
sending himself letters right he was
writing letters hilariously he wrote
letters or letters from himself racist
he was like he was like i'm getting
racist
letters on set oh you were sending them
yeah oh i thought you meant like writing
just writing letters like hey no no no
no like writing letters look what i got
in the mail this is not a good guy it's
all his handwriting
he's not a good guy he misspelled
murderers
no the guy did yeah all right you know
the guy that's coming after me you
struggle with spelling too it's also
like cops like they're not dumb like
doing this this shooting scenario
everything i did was wrong everything i
did was wrong because i'm not trained
and when you deal with trained people
they can see a thousand things you can't
see oh they sniffed this out
in 30 seconds bro the problems didn't
even have to sniff it out most people
were like online everyone's like well
why did i
leave the noose on your neck like well
you know yeah cop cam was like
anybody a victim of this that'd be the
first thing you did and what if there
was a what was going on out there do
they have like a snowstorm there's a
blizzard that's where i am they're like
and when you get out of the snowstorm
getting a sub you know what they say
about narcissistic israel
yeah they say with narcissists that they
they um
almost never think they're gonna get
caught and in fact um narcissists and
sociopaths one of the first things that
will happen when they get convicted
of like a murder or something uh this
fbi profiler was talking about it one of
the first things they do is they look up
in surprise
they go
what
what yeah like they can't believe like
when their appeal and everything's gone
they're like wait a minute you're
actually going to jail in those doc oh
yeah bill cosby the the prosecutors said
she's prosecuted like 70 people that did
rape and these crimes she goes it's so
strange every single one when the victim
is giving their testimony every single
one of them has like this weird like
smurf she's like every single one and
she goes and bill got away with her bill
cosby had the exact same wow yeah a
smirk your face tells the story just
[ __ ] your behavior yeah
yeah he's such a piece of [ __ ] i mean
he'll never work again
oh jesse's smallit
no no
no he's uh
i mean he's just i don't know he was on
a hit show like his show was doing you
know what he could do what he would do
is he would go he would come clean
and then that's never going to happen
therapy
religious no no no that's never happened
i don't know america i mean americans
will give you sometimes after 10 years a
second chance but you know i don't know
i don't know after looking at that
that's a tough one that's a tough one i
don't think he's got i don't think he's
capable you've doubled down oh he's
double down he's just a shitty person
man the worst when he said i did not do
this i'm like wait what's a guy like
this do now
let me go serve 150 days
ride with the blm thing and just preach
about racism there's no money there
there is i'm sure the other gofundme or
some [ __ ] for him there's a lot of
dummies out there yeah
yeah what else you got jen
i think for sure he does a reality show
without a doubt oh really yeah and and
would you not tune in just to see how i
would not tune into
all right
yesterday tom brady had announced that
he is officially unretiring and coming
back were you surprised by this no
yeah really
he's gonna be how old
45 45 he's 44 right
he's as these past two months i've
realized my place is still on the field
and on the stands
that time will come but it's not now
it'll be my third season
23 years as a football player he's such
a badass god
i didn't know he got drafted as a
baseball player too 44 he'll be 45 this
year yeah he could have played he got
drafted to play major league baseball
so
so there is a difference like kevin bay
was talking about this he said there's a
difference between being an athlete and
being athletic yeah an athlete's a guy
who can jump high run fast and all that
and then there's athletic where you can
play a lot of different sports you've
got the skill for it it's an interesting
distinction i never thought of that
kind of interesting right like
brady may not be like the athlete that a
lot of guys are but he's athletic
athletic yeah
that's an interesting distinction
and tampa load up again they get some
big free agents especially tom brady oh
yeah yeah they're going to load up
good for him
oh this is interesting so i couldn't
find exactly where it was originally
posted because a lot of articles had
snippets of it but this is the only
place i could find all of the text
messages i'm not sure how it came out
but there are text message screenshots
between p davidson and kanye west yeah
and it it's essentially i assume kanye
released this because he keeps going man
you're doing lost for publicity like i'm
not about
these cameras how many clothes skeets
pete's friend yeah somebody close to
pete so yeah
yoski can you please take a second and
comment
no i said yes
oh yo it's skeet which is the name kind
of game which is funny can you please
take a second calm down it's 8 am and it
don't got to be like this kim is
literally the best mother i've ever met
what she does for those kids is amazing
and you are so [ __ ] lucky that she's
your kid's mom i just i've decided i'm
not going to let you treat us this way
anymore i'm done being quiet grow the
[ __ ] up he was oh using profanity where
are you at right now but in in
in bed with your wife
cool
happy to see you at a hospital in rehab
he goes same here it's wonders what
those places do when you get help you
should try it i'm in l.a for the day if
you want to stop being a little internet
[ __ ] boy and talk aggressive for pete
yeah um you don't scare me bro your
actions are so [ __ ] and bear saying
it's so sad to watch you ruin your
legacy on the daily and then connie says
you're more than welcome to come to
sunday service i'm with pete on this
because why don't we meet after sunday
service and saints game i'll be at the
beverly hills hotel we can have food and
talk it out in my room privately
one-on-one man-to-man because what are
you doing to your family's dangerous and
going to scare them for life please
handle these matters privately bro i beg
you and he goes you want to see me come
to sunday service which is so stupid
but this isn't public dude i'm not here
for pictures and press which i'll see
all you care about my first stanzo she'd
man up for once in your life that
let me help you man i struggle with
mental stuff too it's not an easy
journey you don't have to feel this way
anymore there's no shame in having a
little help you'll be so happy and at
peace you have no idea how nice i've
been to you despite your actions towards
me i've stopped snl from talking about
or making fun of you which they've
wanted to do for months i've stopped
stand-up comedians
um
i've stopped standing up comedians from
doing bits about you because i don't
want the father of my girls kids to look
bad out there i have your back even
though you treat me like [ __ ] because i
want everything to be smooth but if you
continue to impress me like you have for
the past six months i'm gonna stop being
nice
yeah man you're dealing with comics so
pete's gonna light you up has he been so
he's been really bad to pete the whole
time yeah he made a music video where he
showed pete's dead body wearing it oh
yeah he was like burying it
and then he did and then he did say if
anybody sees him call call him skeet on
the street and then and then kim was
like dude what you're doing is you know
because you know he runs with some tough
dudes i think they're god's disciples or
gangsters jesus yeah got disciples in
chicago at all that's kanye's crew so
kim was like yeah stop this it's
dangerous repeat you're gonna get
somebody hurt and then kind of come out
back hey nobody put physical hands on
them i'll do that if we need to
it's just not kind of this is just
i think what you're doing is he's he's
just a hurt individual
i think there might be a method to his
madness i think he's like look at me
trending i'm trending number one that's
kind of the a lot of this might just be
that do you think that's real and did
that really come from pete is that a
real text director because for him to
say with your wife that that was very
inconsistent with the rest of the stuff
i think your eyes are fine i mean i
think it's real because i think pete's
taking so much [ __ ]
because kim posted two finally
addressing that they're officially
together plus a real picture she did on
her profile right so they're it's
definitely i think it's pretty real
especially the way he was talking like
dude i'm staying here i'm not coming to
your [ __ ] public service like i'm not
doing any of that dude what do i do have
a cup talk at sunday service well he's
like i'm not doing this for publicity
man just meet me in person what's wrong
with you
yeah and then that kind of makes sense
what you're saying then brian because
it's like if he went to the sunday
service then there could be [ __ ]
paparazzi whatever it's like oh pete and
kanye
but that's why pete's saying that no
that goes against this thing yeah he's
saying oh pete's saying i'm not doing
this for felicia i'm not going your
sunday service those cameras and
pictures yeah yeah they come to my hotel
room this is a private matter
but then he made it public that's what
i'm saying pete didn't make this public
he didn't blast that out somebody did
close to it someone did usually kanye
but they didn't have it's
which means pete was it was from pete's
phone whoever screenshots i just love
that we're all talking about it like i'm
actually hated
i don't like it this is the first time
i've ever been interested in this pop
culture like drama but it's interesting
because i was watching kanye because my
girl follows this stuff so i was
watching kanye he gets on instagram and
starts talking about like his entire
life it's unbelievable he's like oh yes
remember why i told you guys blah blah
blah and then well guess what and he
just keeping everybody abreast on
on on i think it's north and how he
doesn't get to see north and how can
which isn't true that's true no that's
true
yeah i think it's breaking news that kim
is getting a protective order against
kanye currently
i think kanye really struggles with
mental health and it's pretty evident in
his rants and tweets and stuff like that
it's not good man he needs and then also
the he needs a lot of help and also the
harassment of kim like that's the that's
what i'm saying the best way to handle
it no that's and even kim just text them
offline like she's like hey man what are
you doing and he posts that and he posts
it yeah he puts you on it's not good man
i think i think he's really mentally ill
i think he's a genius i like connie but
this just ain't the way to handle it no
you lost your girl man like that [ __ ]
you lost your girl maybe because of this
too like that's difficult oh yeah
imagine dealing with that i don't think
she wanted to like have be broken up she
wanted to raise kids are so sweet man
it's such it sucks all the way around
well it's tough i like pete too it sucks
what else you got jen
so there is a model she was on the cover
of playboy africa she's doing a
i guess side hustle where she is telling
girls if you want me to see
to if you want to test your boyfriend
send me two thousand dollars and i'll go
and dm him or text him once you give me
his instagram handles or his phone
number if he is a faithful man and
doesn't try to meet up with me i will
return you your money but if he tries to
establish a day and a time to meet up
with me then i keep your money and
you'll get to know whether your
boyfriend's willing to cheat on you or
not girls are probably eating this up
huh probably yeah i bet she's doing
pretty well yeah yeah it's not a bad
it's not a bad business that's take a
let's take a look at what she looks like
let's make sure let me make sure
everything's okay
okay all right yeah
but what guy's like all right are you
coming to i mean i guess i'll fly also
yeah that's what i'm saying
by the way though it's [ __ ] because
a lot of guys just want to have a
fantasy they're not going to do it
they're just going to talk to her
you know
sometimes it's just a little
just so looks like she would do that
yeah
yeah she doesn't look like she doesn't
look like she's in law school right now
but
she looks short with a big head yeah
that's a big head yeah
i mean she's not a bad looking girl but
but she's definitely a honey trap i mean
there are a lot of guys there for sure
who's that awesome
who's that guy's friend
you're amazing
that would be the one person who catches
brian's eye
that's because he's simply amazing that
is the gay browner conor mcgregor look
at that
he looks sweet oh and he's wearing his
dick straight up is his dick being worn
straight to the to the left though
oh stop it you know that's just for the
left
naughty man boy
there oh oh he's not and he's definitely
straight but she has a head like a
rottweiler she's got her head she's got
a head on her she doesn't have anything
i'm not attracted to that but that's
okay i mean she's pretty hot but there's
something going on for me that's it that
boy got all the sugar in the tank
my shirt
excellent business uh idea yeah it
really is it's a good business idea i
will hunt until guys see this well yeah
now now it's out you know i also feel
like you should kind of know better if
you're like let's say you're a normal
dude you have maybe like 700 instagram
followers and randomly like this one
liking your photos or dm'ing you some
guy that works at home depots like miss
africa wants my dick yeah right i figure
it out
i mean how many of those do you get it
my buddy fell for it my buddy was like
look at this girl i go
he's like she's being she's i go you see
that she steps from ohio but she's she's
talking she's going i would like to make
your acquaintance you look nice person
seven million followers from russia
you're right or wherever you ask you for
money dude unbelievable he's like you
think so i go do i think
i can't even believe that catfish show
still exists they're on like season
whatever [ __ ] 15. you can get catfish
because people are people are still
doing that on the regular oh yeah people
are lonely and people will catfish a
[ __ ] some people are desperately
lonely yeah i think there's a spin-off
called ghosted where they're kind of
running out of ideas for catfish so many
people are privy to to like all those
different ways of catfish people now
where they have a new show
setting two people up one person who got
ghosted by another yeah
they're like what's up why'd you ghost
me and she's like because i found a
boyfriend
like that's the episode
because i moved on [ __ ] boys
i think it's off there now but i know
what you're talking about yeah they
tried it for a season and it didn't work
because they would go to guys and like
yeah dude that's not a girlfriend what
do you mean ghosted i personally i love
uh catfishing back i'll be like
where are you
do you do you need money
put your cash up i'm gonna send it right
now i told you about the guy i had i had
him driving all over [ __ ] jamaica
kingston where he was uh because he was
telling me that he was gonna give me
money and he said i'll give you money
you won this thing
but you have to pay the taxes on it and
i have to pay the taxes for you yeah he
was the lamest thing and i'm like well
how much money is it and he goes it's 42
000 ago and so how much do i have to
give you he goes thirty two hundred
dollars i go uh i don't can i give you
half of it now and the guy yeah so
i go okay just give me the western union
so the guy would be like okay it's and i
go okay and i go is it there and the guy
oh it's not there i go what do you mean
it's not there i sent it and he goes
well it's not there i go well
what give me another western union and i
was getting really frantic i had him
running
all over them he kept calling me i did
it for about two days piece of [ __ ] oh
two days and then finally i went like
this i go i go
he goes it's not there i go it's not he
does not go well then
okay i know what i'm doing i've been
sending it to your goddamn ass
did you check your ass you piece of [ __ ]
these guys are stunning
i was like [ __ ] idiot
well brian can't go to jamaica nope it
was fun to hear brian say well there's a
guy there a guy right a guy i know
what's that it was funny hearing you say
bumblecloth
my [ __ ] uh my uh
the guy who owns i don't say his name i
guess so my buddy travis he got um you
know travis owens
oh yeah so his girl was in
mexico and he got a call he just gets a
call out of nowhere oh yeah they
kidnapped her yeah he goes i kidnapped
you your your girlfriend yeah and i
guess he couldn't get in touch with his
girlfriend and he was going to send
money and it was just this whole school
somehow they found out they found out
she was in mexico because she posted i
think on instagram yeah and then he
found all this they they just find all
yours like freaking out about to send
money and then she was like what's wrong
with you he's like you're not kidnapped
she's like no he's like oh [ __ ] i was
about to wire 30 g's for exactly yeah
and it almost worked it almost worked
but she was she was completely fine and
he knew everything about it because he
had done all the research that would
freak me the [ __ ] out of course it was
these guys get you man what do you got
jen
they go above and beyond just get you
sent some cash
it works all right i don't really fall
oh well i don't fall at all wwe or
wrestling but this guy had his neck
broken while he did a trick and i'll
show you the actual footage of it no oh
okay i don't like this stuff yeah i
can't watch it watch
his name's big e
but he said he's gonna be okay
he's fine he actually posted this
message afterwards
you can lose all can't thank all of you
beautiful people enough for all of your
concern and your money that is right
it's very hard
uh i can move all my digits you see that
that's great yeah that was a good thing
um strength feels fine but unfortunately
uh right now they tell me my neck is
broken so there's that but uh once again
thank you everybody i'm gonna be all
right i'll be good don't worry go to
sleep
don't worry about all me dude
thank you situation and
uh all of you for real
putting wrestling i hate that stuff
that's suplex [ __ ] yeah why would one
always make you nervous he landed right
on his head no never never no no it's
gonna spike on your head because they're
professionals
yeah no one gets spiked on their neck
but when you're when you get it when
somebody grabs you and suplexes you this
way no you know how to fall you do i
don't know what's going on there yeah
all righty all right
this is a woman um actually no this one
first so this la
reporter i think ktla
he was talking about an intersection
that has a bad hit and run
uh thing that happens there all the time
and then there's a hit and run as he's
telling the story that's a great [ __ ]
that's a stroke of luck
yeah you see hoover street here
officials say it's one of the most
dangerous streets in all of los angeles
and now
jesus christ
he just takes off
just more evidence as to how scary it is
here on hoover street we did call 9-1-1
the police came out here to help those
victims out there fortunately they were
not hurt but are very much in shock but
uh so that guy's bumper fell off so they
have his life square
square
make it more interesting be like dude we
were just talking about this and it just
happened
jesus christ did you see that and it
wasn't staged like be more exciting just
[ __ ] square yes there it is like i
told you it's a real problem
hoover street's a problem for many
reasons yeah yeah you don't want to go
down hoover that was impressive
so this is the director of black panther
this is interesting have you heard this
brian no so it's a black teller at uh at
a bank and he comes in to get cash out
he doesn't say anything he just hands a
note hands a note this is the amount of
money uh 12 000 so i would like to
withdraw 12 000 cash from my checking
account please do the money counter
somewhere else i'd like to be discreet
so he's doing that because whenever he
gets money out like people notice
because the counter
he doesn't want to get robbed so he's a
black man you know with a face mask just
hands the note yeah but he also had his
id and his checking card some young
teller you know bank teller panicked
panicked called the cops yeah they told
you that you're told to do that right
away right
i don't think so because if he hands you
your his
id and his bank card and also what bank
robber is trying to get 12 grand when he
asks for more
and there's no threat because but here's
the thing that note is on the back of a
stub well like a receipt artie lang
tells a really funny joke about how he
wrote as a goof he's like 18 and he goes
into a bank and he writes i have a gun
give me all your money yeah he kisses
the woman
and the woman's face goes away
she just gives him a bunch of money and
she [ __ ] like sends him he gets
[ __ ] he's like whatever and she i
think he took some money he was like
that's cool yeah and then he wrote the
bank the [ __ ] judge is like let me
read this out loud
i have a gun
and arnie kept going he goes he tried to
talk and go i can explain shut up shut
up [ __ ] [ __ ] who do you have
judges
you're doing [ __ ] community service
he's [ __ ] sitting there at the docks
and the guy was a mafia guy guys just
sit here
don't rob [ __ ] bank stomach yeah i
mean good thing it was a black teller
not a white teller because then we'd
have a real problem yeah
well but i guess if you're i i would be
nervous about that note but but but the
even though when she's talking the the
the operator on the phone for 9-1-1 the
operator goes uh did he give you an id
and she goes yeah she goes did you look
at the id she's like uh you know he's
just acting weird she's like well he
might just want to be discreet about it
because he's taking out so much cash
yeah good for them and she goes we'll
send you know uh cops out but you might
just want to be discreet with so much
cash she's like yeah i don't know and
hangs up the phone
yeah you mean you get nervous
well
okay elon musk uh went on twitter to
challenge putin
and he put it in his own language as
well i don't think
i don't think uh elon wants that fight
does elon have any background i don't
think he does in any combat sports right
now i don't think so no i'm putting my
money on putin putin will [ __ ] but what
what's the bet if he beats him does he
does the war stop
well yeah what do you mean elon musk
hurrah for this is this
stakes are
ukraine out of here i mean i love this i
love that he did this no it's cool yeah
but
can we send somebody else yeah yeah
i don't know
i got all my money on putin putin is a
black belt in judo and has a bunch of
other combat experience
i think the only thing you got to bank
on is putin's old man
uh
and there's rumors he's doing all this
crazy [ __ ] because he has a cancer you
know what first legacy yeah wow but uh
elon if he accepts the fight can we send
oh i don't know
can we send jon jones yeah
to make sure that ukraine's gonna be
okay
yeah
wait how old is putin 70-something uh no
i don't think he's that old i think
almost 79. so he's 69. so we got to find
a badass 69 year old out here
then go out there and [ __ ] him up yeah
go get him brian can we send mike tyson
yeah
it's a fair one we don't want to bank on
brian either we want to send someone a
real combat experience i uh i would um
what do you think you would do bry
putin's a black belt
he's but you judoka though i know you
and you did he's got a lot of the tricks
but i would he's 70. he's gonna you
would get it so yeah that's good
that's a fair one he's gonna have his
hands full with me yeah but i don't know
i don't think poon's taking a random
fight with you i i think we gotta sound
like a real celebrity it's kind of like
the jake paul thing i love you but
hey but
can you send jake paul yeah
yeah i don't know who you would send you
know but putin's clearly not getting
speaking of jake paul did i hear did
does he actually want to fight conor or
mas vidal in an mma fight he wants to
fight conor did he give a pretty
appealing uh
yeah in the ufc he goes one fight he was
dean if connor beats me
i'll never say your name again i'll i'll
retire he goes but if i beat him you
have to agree to my proposal for fighter
pay
do that if i lose i don't have entire
personal all ufc fighters who make less
than 50k if i never mention ufc again
it's pretty compelling it's very
compelling dana's not going to do it but
it's probably what i don't know do you
uh put your money on conor in this
situation would be a minus three
thousand minus three thousand yeah
i wish dana would do it be so fun yeah
not happening though no
but jake must have a lot of confidence
in himself as a i think it's also
marketing too he knows dana's
yeah
it'd be so cool if dan was like okay
yeah
i don't think he wants to jim was saying
you imagine if uh jake
in some weird world if he beat him like
what happens then dana has to do all
that pace [ __ ]
be hilarious
yeah why why wouldn't he entertain it
just because it's like there's no really
huge upside for dana yeah yeah okay it's
actually all downside for dana yeah i
mean if you have to agree that fighter
panic you know i bet that you want conor
to win and you know
but it would be a massive massive it
would be the biggest paper of all time
for sure
all right i don't follow basketball but
so
um what's his name
jason whitlock jason woodlock who's he
does he used to do mma which he was
really bad at but he doesn't
like you through mma yeah remember that
the he
he was he was on uh fox and then p
people hate yeah his take on him was
really bad he wasn't really
but he does sports stuff he does sports
and everything's like
he's kind of like the tucker crosstalk
yeah for black people he's like he's
he's conservative black guy big time
he's a conservative black guy he's like
candace owens but for sports oh yeah but
he's like he's like an antagonist he was
on he was on out kick all the time yeah
yeah he's i don't think i don't think
i've heard about him a couple times good
guy yeah yeah he seems like a smart dude
but he just he seems like he plays that
he'll so what's he saying not keto
though
show me a picture of him okay hold on
now to protect his brand russell
westbrook
okay i'll show you a second channel
so what's the rest broker apparently
that's jason woodlock
you've seen him a lot probably on
different he's been on her sports show
okay
oh okay he's a sports announcer yeah
user jason whitlock all the time
he played football too uh absolutely not
sir no no bro what's that picture right
there says
i think he did jason
football well maybe he did play in the
car yeah cardinals
uh well that's ball state that's not
arizona cardinals
it's not no that is a college team come
on you might be right
that's ball state that's ball state in
the 70s okay
all right let's see
but we want that ball state offensively
okay there we go so he played that's
cool there you go hey shout out to ball
state right
so
to protect his brand russell westbrook
nike and espn channel jesse smallett so
he's saying what so russell westbrook
went on to say that um i guess they call
him west brick now which is like playing
so bad yeah because he's not a fit for
the lakers in any capacity okay he's
playing so bad he's getting death
threats which i don't i hate that that's
not obvious his family's getting death
threats you're just playing bad but so
westbrook said he had his kid
say that he went to the kid went to
school and was like
he always says his last name westbrook
right because he's so proud of the name
so now that everyone keeps saying
westbrook he says he has to you know uh
stop that from as soon as someone says
he has to stop it immediately because
you know his kid's affected all this
stuff get it so whitlock is saying like
you're bringing your kids in because you
nicknames and you know making fun of
sports people have been around forever
since sports has been there yeah but
there hasn't been social media since
sports yeah but i mean how about this
kid he also i don't know but he's also
wes brick isn't like calling him you
know a really bad name it's just kind of
like he's not making the shots so
that's right the kids getting bullied at
school being called west
he's blaming westbrook of bringing his
kid in because he's doesn't have the
courage to tell him like oh i don't want
you to say it about me it's because of
my kid that's what was uh what like oh
got it yeah so he's saying that he's a
coward you're doing that suck
i don't think russell westbrook's a
coward
i don't of course not no people are
being so like it's like that guy his
wife had to come out like stick up for
him
go so hard as if they [ __ ] play
that's what bothers me it's like like to
get to be him and to be yeah good for
that long
hall of fame yeah he's having a bad
season for whatever reason he's never
been mvp but he's a monster i thought he
was i thought he got it i don't think so
he's such a [ __ ] amazing athlete i
don't think he was the mvp yeah
yeah he is he's a superstar so okay i
mean i guess
oh when he got all those triple doubles
yeah
right yeah yeah he averaged a triple
double i mean
so nuts
i don't even know what that means but it
sounds awesome
but i mean triple double so you score
double points in points assists rebounds
every single game dude
monster so so i'm sorry he's having an
off [ __ ] season he's just not a fit
for the lakers it's just fans are the
worst yeah i can't see when people ready
to throw people away like that i
remember when matt liner he wasn't doing
that well in the pros he never did well
but yeah i know but my buddy was like
he's done he's just done and just i know
but you're a commentator now can you not
like just dismiss the dude like yeah so
yeah as a [ __ ] human a quality human
being man yeah and social media makes it
way worse yeah guys cause you have
access to him now if he you know you
have access to him if he partakes yeah
cause you could go to his [ __ ]
profile and just talk [ __ ] oh let's see
the huge alligator yeah but also even at
games they yell out stuff at the games
too which is just like she yelled at
lebron too
i got a question for everybody
what animal
what animal
universally cross-culturally
has been has always been feared
by human beings
dog
no
crocodile no animal any animal shark any
animal shark anything in the animal
kingdom snakes
snakes
and what are the three animals that when
we were in the trees as monkeys or
whatever what were the three animals
that we
always had to watch out for cheetah
snake
cats
yeah cats snakes
one more thing
what are monkeys afraid of
to this day
birds of prey eagles oh wow now here's
my last thing what's another what's
another mythical mythological creature
that is represented
on caves and art cross-culturally all
over the world throughout all time it's
really fascinating bears not bears
minotaurs not minotaurs it's really
fascinating
snakes not snakes cats not cats it's a
mythological creature a mythological uh
okay bigfoot not bigfoot
not bigfoot
what does it do so think about what you
just said and put all those animals
together
uh the [ __ ] the bird i i can't think
of the name put all those animals you
just said cat bird snake space okay
elijah put them all together put them
all together and what is the animal that
is represented i don't know represented
like cross culturally from japan to
europe [ __ ] give it to the dragon the
dragon
[ __ ] i finally got one a dragon it's
taking me forever and what they think is
that that so chimpanzees if they see a
[ __ ] snake they flip the [ __ ] out and
then what they'll do
yeah and the huge ones and if they see a
snake what they'll do is they will sit
over here
out of reach and stare at that
[ __ ] all day they will not take
their eyes off that thing and they think
also that human beings have incredible
eyesight
we are we as human beings are amazing at
being able to spot snakes in camouflage
better than any other animal when i'm on
that trail you see it right away yeah
and that's because you've evolved that
way because snakes are no joke in the
wild no especially on that trail and
then uh i've had people like god damn
man you know where they're at everywhere
i'm like yeah because if you think it's
a log it's not i'm seeing it right away
right away most animals don't see that
yeah and you've evolved to be able to
see that it's crazy how good i've gotten
at reading those [ __ ] things yeah but
no other animal can see that those
patterns we have we have eyes that are
adapted to that
and it's it's really interesting all
that anthropological stuff i hope you
guys wrote that [ __ ] down
that's
called
this is called dragon's r us what else
you got jen all right this is the last
one so this paddle boarder
people are criticizing her because of
how she handled this situation huge
obviously i'm terrorizing people and she
in unveil killed in florida state park
terrorizing paddle boarder so this
particular one
honestly just look at the video yeah but
don't paddle board you know i know
especially in florida especially around
that yeah that thing so just watch it
listen
no no now that's not a croc so they're a
lot less aggressive
get away from you're the one in his
house [ __ ] all right
no
push them away at the paddle
that's scary
well that'd be terrifying but then she
pushes him like that
i love how you just float and he's like
hi baby [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ]
super friendly push me with that [ __ ]
again punk [ __ ]
it just it looks like it was just
drifting and it just happened to drift
towards her yeah she pushed it in
they're like get out of the water
that's not normal for that thing to be
that confident that too somebody's
before he knows he's like [ __ ] just
wait till you tip over
i'm watching this youtube thing they're
in indonesia and the cops are patrolling
and they see a guy letting his nets out
he's in he's in uh well he's in the
river now in the river where crocodiles
are you can't see anything
and this dude is like like in the water
up to his like thighs yeah and the you
hear the cop go that guy's brave in
indonesian that guy's brave he's very
brave that fisherman and that's what he
does he's been fishing there well as the
boat goes by they go and that was the
last time they saw that fish oh yeah
yeah i mean crops like oh cool nets yeah
then they went to catch the giant croc
that did it and they couldn't find him
because it's a river yeah that was what
he was doing is that's it that's so hard
uh
this saturday fight companion for the
big london card could be a pay-per-view
but the ufc's give us a treat we have
the london fight night 1 p.m pacific
during the middle of the day only on
thick boy you got jeff dye crystal and
myself for ufc london this mother
trucking saturday only on thickboy.com
sign up right now for the tough mudder
april 9th thick mudder it is a 10 30 a.m
start time you do the 5k or 15k use the
thick boy promo code on tough mudder you
can get tension off your entry fee we
also just dropped the thick mudder merch
at thickboy.com if you order this week
you'll have it just in time before the
race april 9th so get you some
hollywood improv is next wednesday march
23rd shaban friends one show uh one
night only eight p.m
that'd be our seventh sold-out show in
row get on it right now don't wait till
next week it will sell out again and
then chicago is also next week thursday
friday saturday chicago schomburg improv
march 24th through 26th my outfits can
be [ __ ] fire and then april 14th
through 16th is stand up live in phoenix
arizona get yourself get you some i'll
see you in louisville kentucky this
weekend kids um thursday friday saturday
and then daddy has miami coming up march
25 26 27 and get your tickets for tampa
florida april 15 16 and 16. oh just two
nights april 15 16. i'm excited so there
it is kids i'll see you there
boom april 8th and april 9th uh salt
lake city wise guys comedy club boom